I'm to call him.
What's up everybody?
Jared again,
today we're talking about a show that's
definitely going to get us d monetized
on youtube.
Bursar based off the Monga,
the same name reserve is one of the
oldest ongoing series out there.
The Nma premiered in 1997 before going
on an almost 20 year hiatus and as
returned with a controversial new
animation style.
Since the show is still going,
we can't quite decipher the entire
message here.
So while guts quest for revenge against
the God hand in Griffith deals with some
fairly obvious themes ranging from
religion to freewill.
No,
no.
Now that any meal,
no cause it to you to Dr [inaudible],
we're going to leave that for a future
video instead.
We're here to talk about the most
visually obvious and philosophically
subtle aspect of the show.
That's right.
Preserves metric crap,
ton of violence Wolgan Ms.
Wise crack condition on the philosophy
of violence in Berzerk and as always,
spoilers ahead.
Now,
I know it might seem like the phrase
mindless violence was coined to describe
Berzerk,
but what's going on beneath the surface
of its bdsm inspired angels and gruesome
deaths is actually pretty smart.
Reserve is unique not only in how it
uses violence to horrify and mesmerize
us,
but also to transform us.
Do you understand the violence in
Berzerk?
We need to consider its genre while the
influences of psychological horror,
cosmic horror,
and even core porn can be seen in
reserve.
The show specifically rests in horrors
monster sub genre according to a
stratasys,
no carol monster horror has two very
important implications.
One,
horror as a genre affords us a critical
distance allowing for a safe space for
fascination to take root.
Simply put,
violence in real life is bad,
but violence on screen is kosher to the
monsters depicted on screen embody.
With Carol calls categorical violation.
They defy traditional categorizations
and simultaneously attract and repulse
for the same reason.
It's these two points that make Berzerk
so well preserved.
Why are we okay with witnessing guts?
Literally slice people in half because
we view this over the top violence from
a safe distance and why do we find these
awful acts of violence so compelling?
Because violence in the show like it's
subject matter defies traditional
categorizations.
This blurring of typical categories and
the fascination and repulsion that it
generates is berzerk calling card.
These binaries can be distinctions
between life and death,
such as when Guts Mo's down at group of
animated skeletons or the distinction
between man and beast and the apostles,
but they can also be less literal.
For example,
Father Mo's goose head bulging sadist,
extraordinary claims to be an agent of
God but is actually serving the demons.
He and his rag tag team of tortures even
gain wings as if they're literally
angels,
Lady Far Niece.
Now seeing the truth behind her order
realizes what they actually are.
No,
even guts the epicenter,
the show's violence embodies this idea
of categorical violation.
He's both a murderer and a hero and
object of religious prophecy and an anti
religious crusader in the original anime
guts is branded as a ritual sacrifice
for the god hand.
A moment that was supposedly
preordained,
but guts managed to defy faith and
survive.
Guts is simultaneously an object of
religious prophecy and a middle finger
against faith or as far DC originally
sees him and how guts sees himself.
Cool.
Thank you.
Let's cut.
Can you cut a [inaudible] molecule down
with day to day?
[inaudible] it okay.
And much like the man himself.
Guts is violence possesses this
trademark sense of categorical
violation.
It repels us.
Get attracts us.
It's animalistic,
yet refined.
This is most apparent when guts puts on
the brazer armor and blurs the line
between man and beast.
His armor even transforming to mirror
this change.
As guts releases a savage cry and
charges the battlefield,
he can't help but notice the compelling
choreographed ferocity here as his
opponent.
Grunfeld note
taken to sue Minneola new employee.
And when guts delivers the final blow of
the first bout,
he does so with a grace that is more
than anything.
Well beautiful.
While it might seem strange,
according to thinker Joel Black and act
of violence can in fact be beautiful in
his book the aesthetics of murder.
He writes,
if any human act evokes the aesthetic
experience of the sublime,
certainly it is the act of murder.
If murder can be experienced
aesthetically,
the murderer can in turn be regarded as
a kind of artist,
a performance artist or anti artists
whose specialty is not creation but
destruction.
Of course,
we're not giving the thumbs up to
murder,
but blacks point is that when performed
with the right craft style and force,
violence can have an almost transcendent
effect on its viewers.
This idea that something can leave us in
awe and transcend understanding is what
philosopher Emmanuel Kant referred to as
the sublime or the state of mind created
when a certain experience stops being an
object of our judgment and starts
controlling it.
Starting to sound familiar like monster
hoard,
the sublime has the power to violate the
purpose in respect of the judgment and
to do violence to the imagination.
It works through a process of
categorical violation,
breaking down the divisions between our
commonly held beliefs.
So how does the sublime and preserve
transform us by forcing us to reconsider
our traditionally held ideas,
specifically beauty throughout both the
new series and the 1997 version,
we are bombarded with intensely violence
images that are in their own way.
Beautiful.
When Griffith in his band of heroes are
monsters liberate for tennis from the
invading who Shaun's Griffith see or
Sonia comments on the aftermath?
No,
you're this time.
Here are the senseless death and
destruction wrought by griffiths army.
Overwhelmed Sonia possessing a beauty
that challenges her very idea of what is
through tapping into the sublime.
Violence in Berzerk frequently becomes a
vehicle for change.
Sonya opening her eyes to the dazzling
death brought by griffith leaves her old
life in the village behind and follows
griffith on his journey to become God
kit,
but for Zurich is very careful to make
sure it doesn't depict all violence as
evoking this sense of awe.
In fact,
the show juxtaposes,
the artful killing of guts and griffith
with ordinary violence,
seemingly common to everyday life,
whether it's the villagers stoning
someone to death or a night whipping a
prostitute from the comfort of his
horse.
These moments are strangely mundane,
petty and underwhelming.
In the end,
these figures,
institutions lack the skill and artistry
to evoke the sublime.
If skill and craftsmanship are the keys
to evoking total awe and wonder,
Ben Guts can be viewed as something like
a violent performance artists.
So what's the effect of guts?
Is a visceral and bloody art doesn't
have a greater purpose or is it just as
French writer tail field got ta calls
art for Art's sake?
While it might be tempting to think it's
the latter,
guts is acts of violence do have a
greater purpose demonstrating the
hideous nature of the societal violence
and ultimately disrupting it through the
distinction between artistic and non
artistic acts of violence.
The show glorifies those that work
against the grain of society,
contrasting them with the drab cruelty
of the institutions themselves.
A prime example is griffith when he's
reporting to the world fulfilling the
wishes of the egg of the perfect world
to up end of the world.
Order
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no,
no to to cure.
So No [inaudible] statutes to Joe,
so stay [inaudible].
She was scared.
Touch
true to this cause.
Griffith and his army.
Take back for Tanis.
In this instance,
Griffith is working against society is
upstart rebel army ousting the coo.
Sean's in one fell swoop,
but once Griffith Regan states the holy
seize control of the city.
He becomes in meshed in the established
power structure.
Typical the violence perpetrated by
institutions.
Ribbons,
violence afterwards becomes tasteless
and crude when guts and company arrived
later at the city,
they find hundreds of slave traders
hanged as enemies of the state bar from
possessing beauty.
This scene is sterile,
methodically organized and revolting to
sharecrop.
Unlike Griffith,
though guts is violence is never part of
a greater societal system.
Guts fights only for himself making
enemies out of whole armies,
religions and even God like beings.
In fact,
the brand on guts is nick attracts
demons and apostles continually forcing
guts to abandoned society.
In the first episode,
guts attempts to reenter society by
agreeing to take a carriage dried with a
kindly man and his daughter.
Guts falls asleep only for his brand to
attract demons who slaughtered the
father.
Daughter duo.
Instead,
guts is curse to live and act on the
peripheries of society is violence
becomes a destructive force upon the
world.
Lady for niece realizes this.
When she becomes disillusioned with the
holy,
see,
as all hell breaks loose on the
battlefield.
Oh,
could I can let us know.
Mrs [inaudible]
Guts is violence invoking the sublime
becomes a powerful force that disrupts
the status quo and forces people to
renegotiate their core ideals for far
niece.
This results in her abandoning her post
and even her God.
Could I take your statement
in tying artistic violence to the
individual and unartistic violence to
society for circus challenging us on
where we focus our attention while we're
drawn to be shining brilliance of guts
is violence or seemingly blind to the
everyday violence that takes place in
the greater world of Berserk.
We as viewers live for the battle
scenes,
the crystallization of violence,
but this ignores the existence of
structural violence or the idea that
certain power structures can prevent
less powerful groups of people from
meeting their basic needs.
True to form.
Look who gets screwed over by society
and preserve it should Doro is
essentially forced into servitude being
the glorified busboy of a mercenary
group.
Costco essentially a mental invalid.
It's singled out for death by father,
most gurus and almost raped by a strange
fertility cult thing and Luca and her
gaggle of young friends are forced to
risk their lives by working as
prostitutes at the base camp,
both servicing military officers while
simultaneously fearing those are very
officer's judgments for circus.
Challenging our ideas of what piece
really is.
We like to think that peace begins when
the battle stops,
when guts has finished putting his
opponents through the proverbial
blender,
but because we can't take our eyes away
from dazzling acts of violence committed
by guts and others were unable to notice
or care about all the other acts of
violence committed by society.
It's in the lols between battles when
reserve decides to show us the artless
and repulsive violence in the world
around them.
In these rare moments when we see people
stoned death or mountains of dead bodies
or even a lake of blood and in trails,
we see the limitations of thinking.
That piece is simply the absence of war
or battle.
But for all those complex intellectual
ideas,
we don't blame you if you only remember
preserve as the enemy.
We're an anthropomorphic horse lik say
semi naked woman and there goes the last
of our youtube adsense revenue.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.
Thanks for watching.
Wise crack.
If you're hungry for more bizarre look
no further than our friends over at
verb,
that's Brv.
They want to give you seven days free to
check out all the shows they've got to
offer made by the fine folks over at
crunchy roll versus a mega service that
gives you unlimited access to channels
like crunchy roll and funimation so you
can instantly watch all the best animate
sub and up,
including dragonball super,
my here academia,
black clover Burrito,
food wars,
season three and of course preserve.
And if you think that sounds great,
verve is giving wisecrack fans seven
days of free hd ad free viewing for all
10 of their channels.
And when you order the Combo Pack,
you get everything that includes
shutter,
where you can get your horror fixed and
verbs select where you can check out
season one of harmon quest and then get
the first episode of season two for
free.
New episode season to launch at 3:00
PM Pacific on Fridays.
So head over to [inaudible] dot co slash
wise crack or click the link in the
description and get your free seven day
verve combo pack.
You can get it on your desktop,
on their mobile APP,
Roku,
playstation and xbox.
And thanks to [inaudible] for sponsoring
this video,
and we've got tons of great stuff on the
way,
including videos on the Emoji movie and
the prestige.
So be sure to subscribe if you haven't
already.
That's all for now.
Catch on next time.
Peace.
Yes.